One of the questions I had was do more viral particles mean that you end up with more antibodies and therefore better
protection?
So that's a theory
So you're assuming that the more viruses you have the more antibodies that needs to be produced in order to attack that virus?
and I think that also have to do with
How much your body is fighting against an infection so you can assume that the higher viral particles that are in your body the more your
immune system has to work to pump out those antibodies to take on that infection.
Cool so I have a question. This question is actually coming from my cousin Katie. Katie, thanks for joining
I miss seeing everybody. I'm glad that we were able to do this on zoom and her question is will this test be able to
detect whether or not people are carriers of COVID-19 or SARS-CoV-2
and also do carriers carry antibodies as well?
So that's a good question so carrier probably meaning that people are asymptomatic so you have the virus
You're not showing anything um the thing with carriers
Carriers, usually just hold on to that particular virus or infection
Um in a case of SARS-CoV-2 I think your body does eventually clear it
But it seems that people who are asymptomatic may not have as much antibodies present
So usually what causes someone to become really sick is like your immune system is working really hard
To pump up these antibodies because you have an attack on your system. And so
This test can see if, this test won't be able to see if you are carrier
But it can see if you've recovered from that illness
what you'll need to test to see if you're a carrier if you're asymptomatic is that previous test that can look at if you actually have
a current viral infection.
All right, so another zoom question and this is will it be seasonal?
That's a good question
I think we're all trying to figure that out
now the thing with this coronavirus and it's like kind of fascinating but not really but like as a
scientist, you're like seeing all this data coming out and it's like
not
Anything that we've all expected or seen from other viruses?
So it's really hard to tell I think there was a paper that came out showing that this virus can actually still replicate
and spread in warmer weather and
so, I don't know if
Seasonal would be the right word because there are other countries that are in tropical regions that also do have outbreaks
And it doesn't seem to be slowing down until you take the measures of social distancing or isolation
Um, so we're still trying to figure it out. That would be
Nice that it like goes away for a bit and like gives us some time to like figure out how we can come up with
These tests and make sure that we're prepared the next time
But the honest answer is that we're not sure yet.
All right, so I have a question from Facebook. So
Thanks to everybody joining us in from Facebook. What are the chances of someone getting the virus again? And how would we know?
That the virus is out of somebody's system if they don't have symptoms ever?
So you wouldn't know
That's the thing about people being asymptomatic. It's like you can walk around like I
Have a little cough. I'm fine, right and you walk around
You don't know if one it's something else or it's SARS-CoV-2 that's causing that
But what was the previous question before that?
It is what are the chances of
Reinfection? So right now there are studies that are showing that you can't get reinfected with the virus
But I also want to point out that these viruses are really adaptable to their new environment
So there are a lot of random mutations that are happening and God forbid that
Happens to a point where it changes it completely where our body now does not recognize that antigen or the surface proteins
you can say that someone can get reinfected with a
different strain of the same virus
And so right now there studies that are showing that this virus doesn't actually mutate us quickly as say to flu
So every year you kind of need a flu vaccine and it changes so frequently
This virus seems to mutate at a slower rate, which is good news for scientists
And also good news for your immune system meaning that that recognition antibodies that are produced
Can keep you protected for some length of time.
okay, so this is kind of related to that and
The question is are there different strains of COVID-19, I guess actually we're talking about the virus itself
And if so, would this have any effect on the antibody test being developed? That's also a very good question
So there's a really nice site called Nextstrain
and so it goes in and inputs all of the genetic data of all ofnthe
Coronaviruses that we've taken from humans who've been infected
And I think the word strain we need to
Be more cognizant of so just because like a random mutation takes place
It's not enough to consider it a new strain if that makes sense
So a lot of mutations have to happen in order for that to occur.
Scientifically, yes, it can happen that these new strains are evolving and they are showing that there are multiple strains
Going around right now, I think in the beginning there were two strains L&S
I think they called it but the good news is it's showing that one strain is not worse than the other
so they're operating the same and I think that's kind of good news
But the question does lend like is that the reason why there are people who are asymptomatic or have worse symptoms?
The honest answer is like we're not sure right now
But what we've been doing there's a really nice database that I've talked about that
you know doctors can and scientists can input that genetic data and we have really good technology where we can map that and
See how that changes over time
So yes, there are multiple strains, but they are all acting the same
okay, so somebody was very very astute and
Noticed the difference between I spike and M spike
Like I mentioned I
Removed a lot of the data cuz I want it to be like as straightforward as possible getting the big idea out
so what these scientists did so there are many different cell lines that people utilize in a laboratory to make
Synthetic molecules or proteins and so one cell line that scientists use is what we call a mammalian cell line
And so these mammalian cell lines are really good at taking up the genetic sequence that we transfected in them which basically means you like
Inject it into the cell via a specific method and then those cells then take their machinery
To pump out this protein alongside all of the other proteins and then you have to go through another process to kind of separate out
Your protein of interest. now I spike is the other cell lines that they use so they're also insect cell lines
I know it's weird, insects, right?
But we can use these insect cell lines to also hijack their machinery to make our protein of choice
What's really nice with these insect cell lines is that they kind of just spit it out
All right
So they make these proteins and they spit it out into I guess the liquid that's surrounding them and scientists
Can then take that liquid and see how much protein that they have
So the reason why we utilize different cell lines is to see if one is more robust at making our thing
But a lot of times certain cell lines can be like hey, I don't like this thing that you gave me
I'm just gonna cut it up or I won't even make it so they use a mammalian cell line
Which is the M and an insect cell line
Which is the I
But they also showed that the mammalian cell line was able to give them larger amounts or quantities of that specific Spike protein
Good question. very nice
So Gayelan asks, do we have data yet that shows how long the IgG antibodies for SARS-CoV-2 are
Present in a previously infected person and would these antibodies be present for a few months, years?
How long is immunity defined? So
You always would have that immunity
The question is how long would it?
Would the virus still be, would the antibody still recognize the virus that will come around?
So if the virus doesn't change and there's not a like a drastic change in that virus those IgGs should be able
to allow that person to be immune. usually people start producing IgG antibodies anywhere from like
It's really really large is like from seven to thirty something days
um, I think also one thing that we're missing is that humans even though we're like
99.9% similar that
1.1% gives us the diversity that we see and our bodies don't all act the same
So it's really hard to see what say what would affect one person versus the other.
So it'll be kind of a question like do we need a booster okay
But yeah, I think we also need a clinical trial to determine. Yeah
Okay, so here's a great question question from one of our rock edu family members
Hi Anika, thank you for joining us
Was there a discussion in terms of the cost of this test
Hmm, will it be offered to folks who are uninsured?
I'm not sure if this was discussed in the paper, but I think these are really important questions. These are amazing questions
So in this paper the goal of this paper was just to develop a test
So they did not talk about like the cost of the test
But I can tell you from the two companies that I found that are selling these FDA non-approved tests
for only health
professionals. So if you're like a doctor if you have a doctor's office, you can buy these tests
I think they're selling a pack of 25 for like $350. So it's probably around $15 a test
And I'm not sure
Insurance company thing is something like way over my head
Like I don't know what they're doing with it and what they'll attempt to do in the future
But I know there are other countries trying really hard to have these tests readily available
For everyone and I'm not sure if they're putting a price on it or they're just giving it free to people.
All right, so a question from Aditi which is how do scientists account for the time lag
where COVID peaks and the time when IgG and IgM antibodies
Levels reach their respective Maxima? How did you determine that time line? Mm-hmm. So they do this based on
So when someone gets infected what you can do is take blood from them
So if anyone's been like admitted into the hospital
They usually like take blood from me at certain points and they can use similar tests to see what antibodies are present
based on
say like the viral antigen that's using this test and
They can take it at several time points to see when they're seeing that peak
But like I said, everyone produces those antibodies at different time points, but I think the consensus is around day 2 to day
seven or eight is when most people starts producing those IgM antibodies and then around
Seven to like 30 something is when people start producing the IgG antibodies
So the only way to know when you're switching or if you have a certain type is actually taking an antibody test.
Okay, I'm going to combine a couple of questions around mutation
so there are questions around, you know do people
have
sort of like
Variations and ACE-2 inhibitor. Sorry not an ACE-2 inhibitor, ACE-2 receptor
um and
another question is around are the regarding the mutating capacity of the mutation capacity of the protein spikes?
Um, so yeah the ace the ACE-2 receptors are a really cool thing that scientists are actually looking into there was a paper that came
Out maybe a month or two ago when this kind of started
In Wuhan where they looked at?
predisposition or genetic predispositions to the ACE 2 receptor in cells
There weren't that many people in a study but it did show that certain people of certain genetic backgrounds have different
variations of that receptor and it may be playing a role as to who
Like recovers and who doesn't do well with the virus
But they're still trying to figure out how that variation works in terms of like is it a genetic predisposition?
Variation. So like are you born with it? Is it something that develops based on like environmental factors?
And I don't think we know that as yet
But there are variations in the amount that we see on ourselves and like I guess the sequence of that
receptor and a second question to that? is um
regarding the spike protein in the
Likelihood of the spike protein mutating in the coronavirus? it can happen. Um, that's the thing with these viruses
I always tell people is like, you know scientists think we're like, we're smart and we can like combat these things
but honestly these viruses have been around for millions of years before humans even like
Hit Earth
and so they've been able to evolve and adapt to many many different types of
environments there are viruses for every organism on earth
There's there are millions and millions of viruses there and they just these mutations happen randomly
They don't really have like the checkpoint machinery like higher organisms have like humans
and so it is likely that a mutation can happen that changes like the
I guess you call them epitopes on that antigen that may now trick the immune system being like oh you
thought you were protecting against me, but actually I've
Changed my protein so that you can't recognize me anymore
It's a good question. So
This might not be an immune question
But it's a really curious symptom of the disease
and it asks is it true that a loss of taste and smell may be a sign of a mild attack of the virus and
If it's true, how do we regain the taste and smell? and that's from Sweetie on Facebook.
There was a paper that came out that showed that this is like the symptoms for people who have like mild symptoms
Where one of the first things to go is like your loss of taste and smell and I remember when we saw that paper
The team and I were like, can we still taste?
Smell okay, we're good
The thing is not everyone experienced that but if you do experience that and then you regain it
Probably that you're recovering from that virus
Or you're in a point where your antibodies are coming where it's removing those viral particles.
So as someone who studies sensory nerves, I'm really curious to know if it's a neuronal thing. I h ave no idea
All I know is that I am
Smelling everything like gym socks and like I'm like yes, I can still smell that they are disgusting
So there's a this is a really great question that I think
Tells me that your talk was good and people are paying attention because the question is
Can these spike proteins be utilized in a vaccine against COVID-19?
Yes, yes, and yes, so I talked about using the spike protein to detect antibodies
But in essence if it can detect antibodies, like could recognize that antigen if we introduce that
viral antigen or that spike protein into humans
Our bodies are also going to produce antibodies for that viral antigen and that's how vaccinations work
I think the CDC has a page on there or another organization where they're actually showing
some of the ways that
Scientists and other companies are going about developing the vaccine and a lot of them are utilizing the spike protein
But there are also people who are using just a top portion of that protein
So I guess we call that the binding domain of that protein. So the part that specifically binds to your cell receptors and
Your cells and so they're just taking that small part and they're also showing that you can produce antibodies
Towards that part
So yes scientists are looking and using these spike proteins or variations of it to use as future vaccines.
All right, so this is an interesting one
Is it possible that a certain blood type would have more or less of an ability to produce antibodies?
It's a good question I do not know the answer of that question and I feel like I saw something like that in passing
But I did not go into it. Um, so yeah, I have no idea
Um, but I'll be really interesting to see if people of specific blood type and I think that's the case for certain other things
So it'll be really cool to see if that's the case with coronavirus or SARS-CoV-2.
Okay, so I'm gonna ask a question of my own because I think it's you know, we have a captive audience and
What are the things that frustrates you regarding the?
Misconceptions of COVID-19 and SARS-CoV-2 - is there something that you think is really important to point out regarding
You know some pseudoscience or misinformation?
There's so many!
We'll be here all day if I go through each one
You know
But also I think it's like a lot of people are in denial that like this thing can wreak so much havoc right on
populations and like I mentioned before we're really underestimating these
Microorganisms right these viruses can adapt really well to the environments, right?
And especially if our bodies have never seen something like that before it can definitely wreak havoc
so there are a lot of thoughts about like
oh like we may have synthesized this virus in a laboratory or
like this is all a hoax and there's no such thing as COVID-19 and so like it's really annoying like as a
Person of like Christian beliefs where you have like a lot of these religious organizations
saying like you know
It's like they're just like hyping this up in news and we don't have to take part in social distancing and then you gather
especially people who are more susceptible to getting really ill from these diseases and people have died with that mindset and
Something something I say, is that okay if you don't believe that's happening still
Regard the guideline. It's like still do the social distancing. Just maybe
Like there's a tiny tiny chance here, right?
But also if you are it still affects us all the same and just wash your hands for 20 seconds
Distance yourself from everyone like we mentioned like some people don't know if they have it they're asymptomatic they have really mild symptoms
So I think it's very important to not put others in jeopardy
like I have people that work in hospital environments that this thing is
affecting everyone it's real and I think we're doing a disservice to ourself when we're putting out these theories out here that
Harms people, right?
It's it's one thing to have a theory that oh if I drink ginger tea every night
I would never get it because like ginger tea is not gonna kill you
It's not gonna kill the next person and it might like help the immune system
But also don't like leave your house drinking ginger tea thinking you can't infect someone else
What about the 5G situation? Do you want to. Oh my god. Yes
so there's this like conspiracy theory about like 5G and coronavirus and
Saying that places that have 5G are also people that are experiencing the symptoms similar to
coronavirus and
So the reason why we know someone has coronavirus is because we test them for the virus. It's called was Koch's
postulates where basically you have to identify the thing that's causing the symptom and so how it works is someone is
Sick, we don't just say like, oh that person has coronavirus, right if they're hospitalized, right?
They're having a really hard time breathing. They're actually testing for that virus particle
So one they have the virus - there are places that does not have 5G that are also suffering from the virus
So if that conspiracy theory was right you'd say that oh this country that doesn't have 5G
They're all you know not going to be susceptible to have any symptoms or having the virus
So look that's BS. Yeah no, that's not the case.
Alright so one last question and I will take this one from the audience
This is from Facebook and Molly Kay who asks, why are people who have had the virus and recovered testing positive for the virus?
That's a good question. So there was a recent paper talking about
How long this virus stays in different
Shedding routes and so usually with the tests we test with the nasal swabs
But it's seen that the virus can and then so they're testing positive with the nasal swabs and then they test negative
But if they test their poop or their feces, they're actually showing that that person still can have viral particles there
So it's like laying around the body so they weren't technically
recovered the test that they used was unable to detect that in that specific passage
But they were able to test it in other shedding routes
So that's a good question. I'm I think it was like kind of weird for people to see that
But yes, they've technically recovered from it
and don't have the symptoms but the virus is still sitting around longer in different parts of the body